[Música]
um dos mecanismos de defesa da mente
humana segundo os psicólogos é A negação
pregação é basicamente um estado em que
a mente entra ou gente se fecha ignora a
realidade
às vezes não liga para algumas vidência
ou tem que esconder Algum desejo por que
no fundo aquilo nos Aços
hoje em dia Parece que o mundo inteiro
entrou no estado semelhante a delegação
eu tô me referindo aqui a pós-verdade
segundo o especialista Lima quintal é o
fenômeno em que uma pessoa se preocupa
menos com Fatos e provas do que com
opiniões e sentimentos na hora de formar
suas crenças pessoais
o que você faz é não só prejudica a
capacidade de análise humana mas encheu
o mundo de pessoas que acredita em
alguma coisa não porque aquilo tem
evidência não porque aquilo condiz com a
realidade Mas por que condiz com que ela
acredita e no fundo é confortável
mas o que a gente tem que entender que
hoje em dia todos nós estamos dentro de
uma era da pós verdade
porque isso agora o ser humano sempre
teve essa tendência comportamental e
também sempre teve que enfrentar
situações adversas problemas ou coisas
que ele não gostava O problema é que
agora
muito muito se diz que por causa do
avanço da tecnologia da Internet das
redes sociais e principalmente dos
algoritmos esse fenômeno acaba sendo
potencializado primeiro porque é muito
mais fácil eu encontrar e me conectar
com pessoas que pensam igual a mim e
assim reforçando o meu ponto de vista
mas também muito por causa dos
algoritmos e das redes sociais que
acabam atuando em cima do chamado viagem
confirmação eu sempre acabo recebendo
informações que apoiam a maneira como eu
penso nunca mostrando talvez Aquele do
outro lado que me faz repensar
pensa assim se o objetivo de uma rede
social é de manter o maior tempo
possível preso a tela do celular o jeito
de fazer isso é mostrando o conteúdo que
vai te deixar feliz engajado e com
vontade de ver
como nosso cérebro naturalmente reage
melhor aquelas evidências que reforçam o
jeito que a gente pensa que isso por
causa de confirmação as informações que
vão aparecer no seu celular vão ser
sempre reforçando aquele lado que você
já acredita Como eu disse Nunca
mostrando o outro lado da moeda
é aí que grupos inteiros de pessoas são
levados a acreditar em coisas absurdas
como teorias da conspiração e muitas
etnias é que desde que você receba a
informação positiva e se proteja da
informação negativa tudo isso é claro
sendo realizada pela internet a gente
sempre vai querer se meter nessa ação de
segurança principalmente quando está
dentro dela junto com várias outras
pessoas
essa informação que a gente recebe como
positiva para o lado que a gente
acredita pode tanto ser verdadeira
quando não verdadeira aqui é a emoção e
o sentimento individual se sobrepondo a
razão e a lógica é o conhecimento humano
retornando aos ideais para iluministas
então que conclusão ele pode dizer se as
redes sociais elas são construídas para
fortalecer esse nome porque talvez não
que propositalmente Mas elas atuam em
cima do viés de confirmação
mas o que falta aqui mesmo é que a gente
não tem como um parar simplesmente de
usar internet para agir usar
redes sociais entre outros o que falta
mesmo é disciplina sobre como a gente
consome essa informação a gente não
percebe mas o salto foi muito alto de em
20 anos atrás se informar cada dia de
manhã através de um jornal e hoje a cada
5 minutos você seria uma informação nova
através de um grupo de mensagem a gente
ainda não aprendeu como conviver com
essa informação e com tanta informação
primeiro a gente tem que entender que a
gente não é dono da verdade e também que
existem simples múltiplas perspectivas
para vários problemas o que você tá
recebendo é uma informação filtrada e
muito provavelmente só um lado de todos
os dias centenas de outros
mas o que mais impressiona mesmo é a
relação aparentemente paradoxal que
existe entre a quantidade de informação
e a quantidade de desinformação mas aí a
gente pode traçar um paralelo com a
chamada infodemia
poderia é um fenômeno reconhecido pela
OMS e que praticamente descreve quando
existe um aumento exponencial da
quantidade de informações de um
determinado tópico na Internet isso pode
acontecer por alguma razão externa a
internet ou alguma coisa que aconteceu
lá dentro o problema é que esse aumento
potencial muito semelhante a de um vírus
traz junto dele muitas fake News e muita
desinformação
muita dessas informações que você vai
estar recebendo como positiva para o
lado que você acredita
essa imagem que eu trouxe aqui ela é uma
réplica de uma imagem que tá uma
reprodução de uma imagem está no site da
OMS e ela não é nenhuma cadeia de
transmissão de coronavirus ou de
qualquer outra doença infecciosa ela é
transmissão de fake News e desinformação
ela é passada de pessoa em pessoa essa
informação que cresceu como um vírus
também é transmitida como vírus e Mas
você pode ver que dentro dessa cadeia
você tem pontos onde a desinformação não
chega aonde a gente disse que você pode
ter tomado a vacina para inflamação
Porque do mesmo jeito que a curva de
infecções coronavirus Quem te falou
tanto no início da pandemia podia ser
achatada a desinformação também pode
aonde é se o ms desculpa recomenda sete
vacinas que a gente pode tomar a fim de
se proteger de tudo isso primeiro
acessar a fonte de onde que veio aquela
imagem que eu recebi Quem é que tá por
trás daquela notícia muito importante
ela é mais do que sol título aquelas
chamadas elas foram feitas para chamar
sua atenção você só vai conseguir saber
sobre o que se trata a notícia depois
que você ela inteira e aí que você pode
mandar ela para outras pessoas
muito importante também três coisas
identificar o autor verificar a data e a
evidência suporte o autor ele é
minimamente qualificada para falar sobre
aquele tema e a data ela tá atualizada
ou uma notícia de dois três meses ou
anos atrás e as afirmações que são
feitas através do texto Elas são tão
menos baseadas em alguma evidência ele é
justificada com fatos
outros dica também seria utilizar o
secadores de fato
no Brasil a gente tem muitos sites e
muitas agências que Já realizam esse
trabalho utilizando tantos métodos
postei acima como também vários outros
se você quiser se você tiver em dúvida
Você pode muito bem acessar algum desses
sites para descobrir se aquela notícia
que está te deixando
angustiado talvez não seja como falsa
mas a parte mais importante na minha
opinião é questionar as suas
pré-concepções é aí onde você adota uma
mentalidade cética e Nacional mas também
científica uma coisa que tem sido muito
necessário atualmente
que eu tô me referindo aqui
sempre questionar esse cético em relação
à veracidade da informação que você
recebe mas mais importante também
questionar a estabilidade das crenças
que você já tem eu sei que isso nunca é
muito prazeroso tanto no início quando
você tem que ficar martelando em cima
daquela ideia que te deixa tão
confortável e vê se você não encontra
algum furo nela ou também na parte mais
difícil assumir quem está errado um
autor de o carne e um de seus livros
disse que você nem mesmo Al Capone e
vários outros criminosos e assassinos
assumiram culpa pelos seus atos O que é
de se esperar da gente comum para gente
honesta com que a gente convive todos os
dias
O importante aqui é entender que errar
não te faz inferior ou Ignorante é
simplesmente parte do processo de
aprender
Por fim eu queria tomar aquela analogia
que eu fiz no início onde eu falo que o
mundo entrou no estado de semelhante ao
de negação por causa da pós-verdade
fechar os olhos por fato ao ignorar a
realidade e simplesmente se blindada
aquilo que te deixa mal não é bom nunca
foi nem nunca vai ser a gente não vai
nunca consegui resolver qualquer tipo de
problema desse jeito e muito menos
chegar ou qualquer tipo de consenso
mas deixa psicologia A negação é a
primeira etapa do enfrentamento é só a
partir dela na nossa consciência atinge
estados maior consegue atingir um estado
maior de qualidade e aceitar a realidade
como ela é através de etapas por exemplo
como a aceitação
não quero a verdade seja algo positivo
muito pelo contrário mas entender que tá
tudo mundo incluído dentro dela e que
todos nós podemos passar por ela é a
primeira etapa para que nesse nosso
reinicializar a gente possa Superar Essa
época tão confuso entendeu Afinal o que
que é verdade muito obrigado
[Música]